coucou ma petite princesse alors tu
passes une bonne journée je suis trop
contente parce que c'est le réveillon de
Noël ouais c'est vrai génial Charlotte
adore Noël soit cool pour une
fois regarde papa c'est joli ce qui
chante on dirait plutôt une bande de
chatci c'est quoi
ça je peux savoir ce que vous faites
dans la cheminée de mes voisins quoi tu
peux me voir c'est quoi votre nom je
m'appelle nicolala
lesc c'est quoi ça c'est des carottes ma
femme veut que je mange sainement et
crois que ça va me faire passer mon
envie de sucre ça mange pas du tout si
vous êtes vraiment le Père Noël vous
pouvez sûrement me dire ce que Charlotte
vous a demandé elle voudrait un kit de
maquillage pour enfants et un scooter
rose c'est vrai c'est le Père Noël j'ai
jamais rencontré de fille de 8 ans qui
n'it pas envie d'un kit de
maquillage c'est qui ces trois là à
première vue je dirais un bonhomme de
neige un lutin et un casse- noisette
j'ai les même à la maison il faut que
j'y aille non pourquoi vous jouez encore
ces garsl veulent absolument mettre la
main sur ma liste mais il y a des
associés là dedans et dit doute de mon
existence oh c'est vrai un
pernosceptique j'ai pas compris quoi un
pnosceptique qui croit pas au Père Noël
c'est un ridicule pour toi mon existence
est impossible mais il y a 2 milliards
d'enfants qui espèrent que je vais leur
apporter leurs cadeau cette nuit il a
vraiment besoin de nous papaù est-ce que
vous êtes on est avec le Père Noël et il
transpire des paillettes et là on est
avec des amis à lui et en fait ce sont
des ramène là à la maison il a pas une
barbe blanche je late j'ai envie de me
rajeunir et je crois que je le mérite
comment est-ce possible qu'il nous ait
cambriolé
our je voulais que toi aussi tu
recommences à
témerveiller vous allez voir
appîue
mag mal
[Musique]
BL
ex que je
traér lesomm ma femme
[Musique]
pon